welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's session pioneering or
understanding of the human brain is my
honor to introduce to you dr. John
Donoghue founding director of the Weiss
Center for bio and neuro engineering dr.
Donahue is one of the most recognized
researchers in the field of neuro
engineering and a founding father of the
merger between neuroscience and
cybernetics his brain Geitner a
technology that aims to restore movement
to people with paralysis has been
recognized internationally and won
multiple awards for complete biography
on dr. Donahue please look at the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. Donaghy will be presenting on
merging minds and machines brain
computer interfaces to restore movement
and communication for people with
paralysis my name is dr. Annette crush
on you and I will be a moderator for
today's event we are delighted to
bringing this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth we like to extend
our special thanks to the brain
initiative program directors and in
particular dr. James nod for their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting your questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located in the far left of
your screen and type your questions and
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions by email
following the presentation the
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
followed the process to obtaining
credits now without any further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. John
Donahue
thank you for the introduction this is
Matt Nagel he has a spinal cord injury
and he's unable to move his arms in his
leg but in fact he is playing this video
game with a tip or a microelectrode
array in his brain that allows him to
think and move the cursor on the screen
so what I'm going to tell you about is a
brain computer interfaces that started
with NASA in 2004 and over the past 15
years has been great advances in how
these brain computer phases work and
what I'm going to do is tell you about
their progress and also about some of
the big challenges we face in making a
device that could work to help paralyzed
people
there's a large community of paralyzed
people ranging from the lady you see at
the top who is completely locked in with
Lou Gehrig's disease or ALS she's
actually this is a video of her she
can't move at all
ranging to a larger number of people
have had a stroke who cannot use their
arms at all or not use it well in
everyday life so brain computer
interfaces aim to help these people
communicate and move again so let me
start by showing you the vision of what
we want this is a looks like a typical
person drinking a glass of water but in
fact this is our vision of how we would
like a brain-computer interface to work
we have a small electrode array
implanted in the arm area of the motor
cortex that picks up thoughts about
wanting to move and this is transmitted
to a radio and signal processor under
the skin that can take the signals and
radios of outside to a small computer
like device worn on the belt and that
device can decode the patterns of brain
activity and then that can be shipped or
transmitted to a stimulator that goes to
wires that innervate that connect to arm
muscles through the nerve and
effectively taking the brain signals and
using them to control the arm muscle so
it effectively made a brain computer -
arm interface that is made out of
physical connections rather than the
usual biological ones that connect our
brains to our body so this is our vision
so I'd like to talk about the complexity
of actually realizing such a dream
so first the big one of the really big
challenges is that brain computer
interfaces require the interaction of
neuroscience computational science
engineering and clinical teams all
working together
the components of building this brain
computer interface are really also
challenging it starts with a neural
interface that picks up signals by
communiques by being implanted or on top
of the brain an implantable processor
that is used to amplify the small
electrical signals and do some initial
signal processing
ideally inside the body and then that's
radioed out to some kind of computer
that can take that data and decode those
brain signals into command and control
signals of using sophisticated
algorithms we then transmit those
signals to a variety of devices that can
be useful to people who are paralyzed
such as a computer for compute
communication a robotic arm is kind of a
surrogate arm for people who are
paralyzed or to their own arm or other
parts of their body like their legs to
restore movement so here's the system as
it existed in 2004 and also as it is
still used today it starts with a small
chip of 100 micro electrodes that is
placed in the arm area of motor cortex
where the signals are for arm movement
today's version of the system has a plug
on the head where all of those wires and
leads come out they're processed and
I'll represent the pattern of neural
activity as a QR code where the black
and white dots represent individual
neuronal activity and just imagine this
is the activity of a patch of brain and
our job is to decode that pattern of
activity and turn it into something is
that can be move a cursor on its screen
and I'll explain more about how that
could work in a minute so since the last
15 years we've shown that people with
spinal cord injury stroke or ALS all can
use signals from their motor cortex to
control computer cursors there's three
examples here there's been more than 12
people involved in what we call the
brain gage study is the device that
we've been developing the system was
developed has been developing and from
those people we have more than 25 years
of experience in and how these systems
work so one of the day
and I'll show you three is the the use
of the system to spell so this is a
person with ALS and she's using the
neural output to copy that sentence at
the top when the sunlight strikes and
she you can see very rapidly pointing
and clicking and Christa annoys group
working with the BrainGate
group in our clinical trial has shown
that people can type about 30 characters
per minute you and I can type about 90
characters per minute so it's not as
good as you were me but it's still very
fast communication for someone who can't
use their hands or speak even more
impressive or a next big step is the
ability from that same tiny patch of the
brain to get signals that can control
something as complicated as a robotic
arm that has to move in
three-dimensional space and grass and
here you see one of our patients Kathy
Hutchinson who had a stroke and she's
drinking for the first time since in the
ten years since her stroke she's able to
lift up her morning coffee and bring it
to her mouth and serve herself rather
than having someone else serve her the
drink
now even closer to the idea of a person
controlling their own body is Bill here
who this is a he is a spinal cord
injured person he's unable to move
except to shrug his shoulders and he has
the actually two of these electrode
arrays in his brain in the motor area
and they're being fed to stimulating
electrodes that are put into the muscles
of his arm so his brain signals are
being used to control his own arm and
you'll see him able to use his arm and
his hand to reach out and grab his
morning coffee cups
you
you
you
so you can see in each of these cases of
controlling a cursor to type to
controlling a robot arm or even the
person's own arm they're really an
impressive advance for people who are
otherwise completely paralyzed but
they're not as good as a typical person
and you can see by the wires and
connections that these people have this
is not a system that's usable at home at
the current time it's still a research
level device so there are a number of
challenges that are left that will a
really big challenges to overcome in
order to make this a human ready device
so some of them are in the area of
neuroscience and computation in
engineering and also in the clinical
domain so what I'm going to tell you
about now is how we've chosen the area
the the problems with decoding the
neural interface development that's
ongoing to improve the quality of the
device and the final steps towards
making a practical system for everyday
use for humans
so one is a one area we choose and many
of you would are familiar with the
famous homunculus which suggests that if
you wanted to get signals out from the
motor cortex to control an arm you need
to have electrodes over a mini
centimeter square area of the brain and
but this map thanks to the work that's
been done actually with humans and
non-human primates shows that that in
fact they organization is not quite this
way and we have to actually go back to
ten fields in jasper in 1954 who made
the original map but warned us that this
is actually not how things are organized
in fact now when we've looked at higher
resolution we can see that that tiny
patch where we're recording actually has
a much more complex code for the entire
arm inside that inside that each little
area of the motor cortex like that QR
code I used as an analogy so in fact if
it weren't true that there were mixed
arm and hand and shoulder and elbow
information in that small region then
bill wouldn't have been able to reach
and grasp his coffee cup let me just
show you an experiment that makes that
organizational advance a little clearer
so this is an experiment done by Carlos
Margit or one in our group and it's
really I think an elegant experiment in
which he showed in monkeys that he could
reconstruct the entire arms movement
from one small patch of the motor cortex
so here's what he did is he trained a
monkey to reach and grasp out two toys
that were swinging on a string so a cube
of all other different shaped objects
and he recorded from the brain while the
monkey made of these reaches and graphs
and he also recorded the monkeys arm
movement so what he was able to do is he
was able to show a movie that showed you
exactly what the monkeys arm was doing
and that's the ghosted image and then he
used the neural data from that small
patch to reconstruct what the arm could
do and what you can see is that all of
the arm in the solid part of the movie
the solid reconstruction is moving
fingers wrist elbow shoulder are moving
and although it's not a perfect
reconstruction the reconstruction is
pretty close to the real thing that is
if it was perfect that both of the
shadowed image and the solid image would
be together and they're a little bit off
so what this demonstrates is that we can
actually from a small sample in the
cortex reconstruct a lot of what the arm
is doing
why we can't reconstruct it completely
accurately remain the mystery of
something that we need to investigate
deeper in basic neuroscience research
now let me give you just an intuition of
how we can turn those patterns into
predicted movements of a cursor for a
paralyzed person so what we do is we
show a patient that has has an electrode
array implanted a movie of a cursor
moving on a screen so the movie that you
see is a cursor that a computer is
generating you can see the cursor is
going left or right and what we do is we
say to the person imagine you're moving
a mouse that's moving that cursor and
when they do that the that generates
patterns of activity in their brain so
does a pattern on the top might be
generated with the right word thought of
movement and the left word the movements
imagine movement would give the bottom
pattern of activity and what we do then
is we store those patterns in a computer
and then we say to the computer in the
future when you see that pattern
move the cursor in that direction top
pattern move it right bottom pattern
move it left and you remember from the
earlier slides that I showed a cursor
moving on a screen and of course it
isn't perfect like the animation from
the computer you can see that it's
irregular a little bit slower than
normal and the reason for that again is
that we have an incomplete sample those
black squares on top of the QR code show
you that we have a really impoverished
or an incomplete sample so we need
either algorithms that can make up for
the missing information or we need
better samples so one of the ways that
we can get better samples is that's
better electrode and the electrode
that's been used in every single human
study so far is this electrode array
that's been developed by Dick Norman
that's placed by a surgeon into the
motor cortex and it leads out to the
outside via the plug on the head now
these electrodes are really a marvel of
engineering but in fact they have some
issues so we'll see - one is is that the
material on them degrade so that they
last as long as we would like and they
only get one sample of neural activity
per penetration per electrode so first
problem you can see that these pictures
of electrode tips on the left is what it
should look like that the control
electrode that's never been used and
that there's a nice plastic insulation
to the tip which is required for the
electrode but after a year in the brain
that elect that insulation begins to
degrade because the body attacks it and
when it degrades the signal quality goes
down so here we see just a graph that
shows Z is the impedance of electrode of
a measurement of leakage and amplitude a
MP is the size of the signal and you can
see both of those decrease over time but
if you look at the time interval it's
over years and when the the lines
intersect with the dashed lines that's
when the electrode is expected to be
completely ineffective so these data
were taken from original experiments in
monkeys and based on a lot of
observations over a thousand showing
that in fact you know we can get very
important data on the lifetime of these
electrodes and that we can show they
last for many years and in fact the
electrode that was in Kathy's brain
where she controlled that robotic arm to
drink her coffee was had been in place
for five years and was still functional
so we know we can make electrode arrays
that last for many years but of course
we really need them to last a lifetime
so they can always be functional
so there have been a number of
innovations recently although there's a
still a big transition phase to go from
animal work to human but one of them
that is most exciting to me is this
electrode that's being developed by I
mecha by Tim Harrisburg Duda and a
number of other collaborators this
electrode has on it more than 960 sites
so remember each probe on the electrodes
we use now has one these probes have 960
the digitizer can record 384 so we put
several of these electrodes in we could
record not a hundred neurons but 10,000
or more neuron the only problem is is
that this device is as you can see on
the left side is rather large it sticks
up out of the skin and so it will have
to be miniaturized more and have
electronics and the other problem is
that if we have thousands of channels
coming out the data rate is higher than
anyone can handle a radio cast
broadcasts that much information the
power demands are huge and we don't know
the safety profile so those are all
things that have to be overcome to make
an electrode this cannot can work all
the time in a in a human with a with
paralysis
now lastly the practical human system is
going to require something that can be
used at home allow the person to be
mobile and you can see Kathy sitting in
a real chair here and the yellow arrows
point out how there's a big cart of
electronics there's a technician in the
room and the plug on her head has a big
amplifier that's attached to it in order
to amplify these signals and so these
are things that have to be overcome to
make a practical everyday system so one
of the very important steps forward is
to be able to implant the electronics
inside the body so here is Matt with his
device attached just to give you a sense
of the size of this attached electronics
and here's what we're aiming to do it's
from the movie and you can see this
small flat object this would be
implanted inside the head and this is
something that I've been working with my
colleagues at the vCenter in Geneva
which is a translational neuro
Technology Center using industrial
processes funded very generously by hon
George Lisa and his philanthropy to make
this hundred channel amplifiers that can
actually transmit more than a hundred
channels at very high bandwidth out of
the body so this is a major breakthrough
it's going to take a few years for to be
realized but it's coming now
so the translation to humans is really a
very complex and challenging process as
I said it takes the integration of many
disciplines we need a neural interface
that will allow us to sample large
numbers of neurons and will be
long-lasting will last in the brain for
a lifetime
we need a implantable processors and the
implantable processors as I said are
coming soon we hope to have them
available for humans in two or three
years we have to decode this information
and we can admit that the kind of
movements either cursor movement or
robotic movements are not typical of
everyday movements so we need better
understanding of the code in the brain
in order for us to be able to produce
realistic naturalistic Lubin's we have a
number of useful devices to connect
those two and I think we can be very
encouraged that we can connect the
computer or robotic arms or hands or
even back to the body there's even a
group trying to attach the brain signals
to the spinal cord to restore locomotion
so the future is very exciting now
lastly the neuro tech we can see has the
potential for many many benefits for
people with paralysis and people with
other disorders as well we can see that
restoration of function is possible
although it has room for improvement we
can eventually create independence so
people who are paralyzed are not
dependent on others for everyday life
and since they are independent we can
reduce healthcare costs so that these so
that they are not so dependent on a
healthcare system and very expensive
care and finally one of the things
that's very important to consider when
we start recording from or stimulating
the human brain is the ethical
considerations of course we need to make
sure that these kinds of devices are
accessible to all there are very
expensive devices and we have to find
ways to make them affordable we are now
capping into the brain so there is a
privacy issue
their minds how do we protect people
from not having their thoughts broadcast
to others and and can we in fact use
these kinds of systems to evolve kinds
of mind control things we have to think
about we also have to be careful that
people don't make claims about what can
be done with these devices that are not
true this is certainly a
misrepresentation of what you could do
is an ethical challenge and lastly a
challenge that will come in the future
is augmentation what happens if we can
alter the body and provide function that
we ordinarily can't have so with that
I'd like to say that all of this effort
requires a very large team my colleagues
at Brown is the VA hospital Mass General
Case Western Stanford and that the
vCenter are all part of a very large
team who have been working together and
it made all this effort possible but
with that I thank you very much for your
time
Thank You dr. donahoo for that excellent
and engaging talk please remember that
our speaker will follow up any questions
about his presentation by email coming
up next
join our first presentation in the
clinical updates track as we hear from
dr. wolf Julian Newman will present for
its artificial intelligence based
adaptive deep brain stimulation and
movement disorders please join us there